quel des gens qu'ils soient isolés parce
que c'est des politiques ou ceci cela à
la rigueur ça je pense que ça peut se
comprendre par contre quand on voit
l'état des cellules 9 mètres carrés je
pense aux formules à l'essai mais même
en formulant les chambres d'hôtel ils
sont belles à la fois non mais c'est
vrai quoi est honnête ça c'est ça c'est
complètement inadmissible parce que ça
s'appelle de la discrimination quand tu
as fait quelque chose et tu finis en
prison tout le monde doit être jugé
pareil et tout le monde doit être
condamnée pareil qu'ils soient isolés à
la rigueur je pourrais le comprendre
mais pas de pas dans ce genre de
cellules qui après il ya un autre
problème en fait très honnêtement moi je
t'écoute parler depuis tout à l'heure et
j'ai vu un depuis une semaine et puis
les reportages sur netflix machin bidule
où tu fais un petit peu le clown
ça fait
quelque chose à à tous les citoyens et
je pense que ça c'est dramatique par
rapport à ce que tu as fait tu vois
quand tu dis j'arrive en prison avec une
limousine et machin ou bidule par
rapport à ce que tu as fait quand tu
quand tu voles l'état 280 millions
d'euros tu as volé tous les français
parce que l'état en fait il n'a pas
d'argent à l'état c'est nos impôts qui
remplit sont les caisses d'état et quand
je vois des gens qui arrivent à sourire
parce que tu fais le clown sur les
plateaux télé et qu'on entraîne peu
médiatisé aujourd'hui et presse que tu
vas finir en héros moi sincèrement ça me
retourne le ventre parce que il faut que
tous les citoyens soient conscients que
tu as pris de l'argent dans les poches
de tout le monde en fait par rapport à
ce que tu as fait et ça je trouve ça
inadmissible sincèrement
et oui la page et sa
victoire du oui alors attends 33 là ces
gens gèrent ce que je pense être la star
sait même pas de quoi tu parles le temps
est radieux
limousine est là pour
nous il est d'abord au quand tu vois la
td voilà réellement la limousine c'est
du cinéma est ce que moi je me rends
diminue avec médiathéque un lien avec
mes impôts tue parce que c'est de
l'argent que tu as volé il a quand même
payer que mais là c'est différent c'est
que toi la seule différence c'est que
toi tu va [ __ ] le bordel dehors dans
la rue pour arrêter des gens de travail
électoral et on n'a jamais su qu'elle
allait se finir versé par aig s'est pas
laissée par les eaux je travaille
on est soit par l'échangé mais tu ne
bois pas avec moi laisse moi parler je
te le dis et qui laisse moi pas mais
t'es qui toi et toi t'étais qui toi oui
toi il nie toute attente prison mais je
suis là haut a fini ses marques
à laisser aller à l'essai pour défendre
les libanais au niveau des volets
roulants par des bombes sur la terre
comme mélenchon tu attends les jours
parler en criant cris en criant allez
allez y sont la seule différence il fait
quoi on t'écoute ils voient l'argent des
gens ils habitent dans les beaux
quartiers et idées pour bientôt alors
bamako défend restons sur le sujet
attend sur le sujet alors marc ok c'est
à dire des choses que je vais te dire
moi que j'ai fait je l'assumé moi j'aime
tout ce qui est beau la seule différence
c'est que je veux pas les criées j'ai
faim dehors je me suis servi j'ai jamais
dis et je me suis servi j'ai distribué
tu peux comprendre que ça me dérange que
tu te serves dans la poche des français
d'accord mais pourquoi il ya pourquoi
les politiques vont quoi mais attention
je dis d'emblée contre les femmes
est dans la même classe que en fait
d'accord si gentilles sais pas si je
voulais faire la politique il ya une
chose que je vais te dire aux menteurs
ma main parce que je t'ai expliqué john
la politique qui sont un peu comme moi
ils inventent n'importe quoi on pourrait
toucher du doigt jetons bras l'avantagé
c'est je crois en dieu dieu m'a mis dans
la lumière du ska quand je sais pas mais
la différence j'ai envie d'y être parce
que c'est tellement beau tu vois dit
fière de mon côté mais pas du tien
la lumière mais légalement et
correctement les chaussées sont là tôt
il ya des gens qui ont connu la lumière
mais ils ont fait les choses
correctement accord s'envoler les
contribuables entraîne on est toujours
en train de dénoncer les politiques on
leur en met plein la tête on peut pas en
mettre plein la tête aux politiques
avoir quelqu'un comme toi et dire que tu
es un héros va devoir passer le jeu posé
une seule question répondre à ces deux
cartes spéciales alors je te dire
allez-y marcory une seule question je
t'écoute tu viens là pour défendre les
autres oui bah ouais t'es dans quoi leur
incident majeur s'il n'aura pas qu'ils
sont pas montés dans la lumière si mais
ce serait se sert de l'émission de faire
passer son message
aujourd'hui on a une tribune grâce à
cyril de pouvoir parler en direct des
légendes à des tarifs et ça
comme ça mais je suis du manque à gagner
à d'état comprenez c'est du manque à
gagner j'ai pas entendu levée du manque
à gagner à elle c'est à dire qu'on ne
sait pas c'est pas de l'argent qui
aurait été redistribués à dire que ça
veut dire mais non mais tu peux me garde
à baba décote jamais à l'école mais bien
à l'école lac selby que j'étais à
l'école non mais moi j'ai jamais été à
l'école alors mais la seule différence
c'est dommage je sais que c'est du
manque à gagner